fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
fresh off the boat or the plane the
legend the legend up in here well this
it's it's very loud Brian I am I will
always bow down to Frank Yeager bet your
sweet ass you will well you know I mean
it it's an impossible career an
impossible business you made it to the
top and one of the best to ever do it
thank you and you're fresh off the plane
from Jersey fresh off the plane that's
not a short flight my man no no I
appreciate you doing it yeah no glad to
come out here kick it with you guys I
saw I saw a clip though before is it
yesterday maybe the clip came out
yesterday you're doing uh like WWE
wrestling yeah I did it [ __ ] yeah I did
it it was Saturday night it was in my my
hometown uh one one of the Toms River
guide to his retirement match sting was
there uh Jerry the King was all over
there Sergeant's daughter oh you're a
wrestling fan uh I mean when I was a kid
maybe not as much now yeah you know but
definitely now that I'm into an adult
yeah yeah look look out there chin
well it was kind of wild because they
told me like 20 minutes before this we
talked about what we're gonna do we
didn't train we didn't drill we just
talked about it
[Applause]
is it a little weird going from like the
real deal to that for you uh I mean yeah
this was just a joke it's still physical
yeah yeah it was cool set it up ah and
this is Nova he had his retirement fight
the the big guy yeah yeah
I think back in the day he looked a
little different you know
that's cool
living such a life right and we're
training that all that it's an extreme
lifestyle in a lot of ways right well do
you are you apprehensive now you you've
retired you've done everything you could
in the sport it's got to be weird man
yeah yeah no I mean I I you know I wish
I could do this forever honestly I I
enjoy training I like the whole
pursuit of a goal you know having that
you might be doing it since you're a kid
you know you're an athlete forever and
you take that you know always trying to
improve and get better and and strive
for something you take that away it's
like damn what am I gonna do but you
know I'll find something did you because
they and I like the UFC did this on your
last fight he was like this is his
retirement fight like we knew it was
your last one we went in I wasn't crazy
about the opponent and I was giving the
OC [ __ ] about it and then somebody for
your team was like Kate Frankie wanted
this that Chris uh Gutierrez I I didn't
want nothing
Frankie won this fight really no I
thought we heard right I told Mark and
Ali I said because they said oh you know
they're trying to pick opponents I said
I don't pick opponents I never in my
career picked up on it I said [ __ ]
you guys tell me who I'm fighting I was
hoping for like a dominant Cruz yeah
that's what I wanted I wanted
a perfect you know kind of the
trajectory yeah yeah have you got you
guys never fought no Legends oh dude
because that Chris Gutierrez I'm like I
just don't even if you beat him I last
one mascara Garden that's dope but it
was like oh man yeah yeah I mean anyway
it worked I honestly I was happy to get
in the car I got a car super late too
that's right I mean I knew I was fine I
knew I was gonna fight that that was the
date I was I was looking for but I got
in the car like six weeks out you know
and it was wifey like did you tell her
like this last camp like Tom yeah
situation yeah yeah yeah last last one I
honestly I thought I was going to be a
guy that was never gonna say I retired
she's gonna walk away but I was like you
know if I don't say it I probably
[ __ ] never do it so I'm kind of
holding myself accountable do you have
any regrets like how do you feel now uh
I mean you know I I wish it went
different you know yeah like the last
couple of my my career didn't go to
where I wanted to but uh I mean [ __ ]
what are you gonna do yeah well I mean
you did everything literally everything
you could think of doing I I I I could
make the argument too that you didn't
get the belt but you you that was some
of those decisions were controversial
well 55 I got them yeah that's right
I apologize I apologize all right so
he's like Frank I'm sorry you never got
the belt no no no that's that's right so
so now you really did do everything you
wanted to do I just made it 45 though
some of those fights yeah they were
close I mean yeah you could very very
touched all those pretty close that's
what I mean you can make the argument
that when Henderson
I would sit with your family because
that was in my hometown Broomfield yeah
I was in there with the family they
looked at me like that does Frank Adam
like easily yeah
what I know that's what I'm saying so I
love so many things so many of those
like that just didn't go your way for
whatever reason because that's the
business was that at 55 [ __ ] I thought
it was 45. I know that Benson Henderson
fought it 55 but
but um I remember when I was so high on
your ear Rodriguez I come in all crunk
because I was a Taekwondo guy and I'm
like taekwondo's here guys and Brandon
goes yeah I know I I know I know but
that's great but it doesn't work against
the higher level guys I go uh excuse me
sir yeah it does that tornado back
kicking wheel
it could be a worse
then they give and you go after they
give them to Frankie and you go but
don't give them
Edgar don't do that and and I always
wanted to know like because he was doing
some [ __ ] that a lot of people weren't
doing he probably thinks that you didn't
see in sparring Camp how how was it that
you were able to kind of break that [ __ ]
down right away just close distance yeah
Mark Marx just close the gap and get it
on him and that's it so he kicks he also
has a super power on his team in Mark
Henry yeah yeah who I've worked with I
worked for my Crow cup but she'll worked
with him a lot more right because he'll
analyze the guy like here
he's done coaching oh is he done he's
coaching I'm done he's got Corey
Anderson and Caitlyn uh 2K Games oh hi
okay they're both kind of on their way
out it's true so he's done and he also
has the best pizza joint he does it's
his pizza what's it called Pinos oh bro
I'm telling first time I met him he
[ __ ] call me by the way he goes I I
mean it was two I got too many texts
he's going though the pizza the dough
I'm getting like [ __ ] paragraphs
about dough I was like hey dude I'm
literally busy it's uh it's a Saturday
so nice you're upset seriously Pizza
can't beat it yeah it was great and then
so Mark Henry I flew out there to train
with uh Frankie and the boys and really
to get with Mark Henry because that
phrase this Mastermind I was at henzo's
I went to Mark Henry and then we're in
his uh he's the nicest guy and a great
family yeah and he's like let's go to
the basement okay this is weird and then
I I he goes uh take your shoes off take
my shoes off and he's like just shadow
box for me then he has seven pages of
notes as I'm Shadow Boxing
he actually had one one pro fight and he
kind of he had like a two-way wire with
the harder yeah yeah he couldn't
couldn't continue but he was a European
Champion uh Golden Gloves champ all that
stuff and then he's the one guy can
translate to MMA so if you listen to
Frankie's fights it's literally like
March playing a video game
they switch it every time it's like a
NFL offense coordinator with the plays
and he just goes and frankly yeah he'll
wear like something some like the QB
thing another level and he's so stressed
out when you're fighting
I have to tell him on Fridays on Miguel
Friday I don't want to hear nothing
about fighting yep shut it down today
tomorrow pick it up I feel like you're
you you picked up boxing so quickly like
your footwork you just looked like a
real boxer like for a guy who is a
wrestler
boxing looked like it came yeah I mean
honestly I got to give it to Mark Mark
was my only boxing coach you know but uh
I I just was well I think boxing you got
to be willing to get hit you know I was
willing to get hit I think yeah was it
was it Maynard Keynes who was it you had
a crazy [ __ ] fight back and forth
Maynard yeah Maynard yeah both three
times
it was just good I think in today's
culture they probably would have stopped
the fight I agree but I agree yes but
when you train when you trained for was
you were coming up because I know
Brandon had this and I think it's I
think it's different now correct me if
I'm wrong you guys would would get in
the ring and bang I mean is that true
yeah so guys were getting [ __ ]
cracked in the head pretty hard yeah you
didn't know any better no it is but in
the beginning especially you know I mean
like three days a week three days a week
three days a week yeah and and is that
different now yeah I started going down
to two days a week but still spawn
pretty hard I mean you find good people
to go with yeah you know but then his
coach would like hire a giant kickboxer
and he could say you knock him out
here's a thousand dollars we go to
boxing gyms that's usually where you go
to boxing gym and you know your only
white guy in there and it's all give you
dirty looks yeah they don't play it no
they they hurt you they're trying to
knock you out
but yeah but also like later in the
career too like Mark Henry because he
got some notoriety because of your
success then all those other guys
started coming there like who had Marla
Mirage
yes
the whole boys were there
yeah what happened is the beat you know
I I honestly he's kind of a quiet dude
so you know we train we don't really we
didn't hang out that much I guess you
say but uh I don't know if you got
something happen with a medical issue or
what well he what this is so he retired
and then uh he was waiting the UFC
wasn't giving like the 5 right so I was
like this is stupid so then he's like
doing something in the medical field
he's not a doctor but he's going to
pursue to be a doctor yeah
but I the beat when he was first coming
he had like a one fight in the OC Mark
DM me and was like job I'm telling you
dude this is the beat kid is the best
I've ever seen he's gonna be world
champion everything wrestling since then
I was like I'll pay attention he's the
hardest sparring rounds I've ever had in
MMA is that right oh everyone says that
he's like I'm talking because he's six
two yeah he's six two tall this is
ridiculous yeah he looks like the
hormone monster yeah
so look at him there okay
yeah he's younger than me there he is
right there
man you're so good at those things oh my
God
ah it's funny but he was such a Savage
dude Savage and Mark was like I'm
telling you he's like you know know the
guys on my Camp the beat dominates yeah
Abe Lincoln yeah hey blinking how do you
suck that kind of weight was he just
super skinny he's definitely skinny yeah
he was [ __ ] big dumb that his
movement he was like good at everything
yeah he hits him with the saddle of
stretch
too right yeah yeah yeah did he come out
of a khabib's camp no
um he's a Dagestan fighter yeah
not everyone from dog stunts how to
compete well I believe they are I tend
to stare they're all close
like some yeah his background was
different that's what Marcus talking
about oh I know where he went he was
like he's like this kid's different he
doesn't win win chant like like his Kung
Fu he went to a school I believe where
it was like literally a place where you
did Sports where you studied fighting
wrestling but also uh like everything
from literature to science there was a
guy who ran uh a school for boys no like
all these Doggers things they come they
they didn't wrestle they didn't grow up
wrestling they could wrestle their
wrestled yeah yeah you know what I mean
they just read yeah he's an insulin
because he was like just sick of like
the politics of DFC and he thought their
demified Daniel fight then he was just
what like one days ago I retired I think
he I think he died like he's he's like
like super popular where he's at I think
he's doing all right yeah I'm sure he's
smart dude yeah he's going to Mexico he
posted a picture of him like in a
nurse's office he's got horses and [ __ ]
yeah he's a gaylord [ __ ]
[Music]
doctors medicine
other people are like are you the beat
also to be your hair you're you're not I
don't yeah
if you're gonna be a surgeon right I
don't want that beard hair in my [ __ ]
in my innards I also don't want those
hairy arms that's a very hairy man
if he comes in first of all he looks
drunk all the time I'd be like sir why
don't you have a mustache why do you
have that much hair on your face isn't
it great though he just was thinking the
balls because like I'm out and he's like
top four in the world I love it I love
it and we never adopt the fight it's
kind of a shame did you ever want to
quit or did you always love it yeah I
always loved it you did yeah yeah did
you do you ever do you think maybe you
want a coach I'll coach yeah I'll help
guys out now I've always been helping
guys on your kiddos my kids yeah my kids
wrestle uh they want to fight you think
my middle guy does he says he does but
I'm kind of like let's worry about
wrestlers where am I getting in college
you know do that from there did you
ready I did yeah which word went to
Clarion University so it's a day one
school Western PA but like everything
else D2 so it's kind of a small school
yeah Kurt Angle went to my school oh we
did yeah but then also I weren't you
guys uh wrestling at Rutgers too I was a
car I coached at Rutgers for a couple
years and I tried I trained there
throughout my whole career yeah the
stress Factory's down there yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right great Club yeah
fine hey I I did I did stand up oh we
saw a clip of it yeah we brought up on
the show here we saw a Clipper I didn't
see it was good a little rush you know
not now that I mean dude I was nervous
as hell you know but I did write most of
the [ __ ] for your first I did write most
of the [ __ ] for your first time out
there yeah
and uh it was cool it was cool I did it
[ __ ] you know what I got offered uh they
had just asked me to uh do the MMA
Awards present an awards uh yeah it is I
forgot to get back to Adam uh to the guy
anyway I'm sorry I think are you going
to be there am I gonna do it no I'm not
gonna beat it it's like tomorrow or
something is it yeah it's like it's soon
I don't know when my bad yeah you're all
right
um but stand up uh uh you had fun doing
it was fun it was cool it was a good
experience I mean I don't know because
they brought up they're like Frank get
this down like yo that's [ __ ] great
yeah it went well the crowd was MMA
fighters
no I mean the Adam Ashley I'm like
[ __ ] I'll try it you know I'm down to
try [ __ ] that scares me you know I don't
know if I'll do it again the only reason
I do it again is I think I could do a
little bit better yeah but I don't know
if I do it like don't get bit by the bug
yeah yeah were you nervous oh you know
what it's crazy I always say fighting
like fighting I'm I'm nervous in the
back as soon as you go out there in your
[ __ ] cage nerves go away it's like
the opposite so you just get on stage
like holy [ __ ] I got the nerves it gets
even worse it's not going well yeah oh
my God [ __ ] Matt Sarah Matt Sarah I'm
at the lab Factory Matt Matt's a wreck
and he's got to stand up for that
looking for a fight was that Matt Dana
Dana and den Thomas yeah yeah yeah so uh
I didn't know that [ __ ] Tony hash
Club had written Dana's jokes but Dana
did a great job with the [ __ ] jokes I
thought he had written them so I didn't
know so much yeah yeah he did a great
job but uh but Sarah was Sarah was so
nervous but he got up and he [ __ ] did
a great job he's hilarious period
but we get up so he gets off stage and
he's so excited I go to I go to kind of
like you know kind of go good job like
that and he's so excited that he goes he
just comes over and he meant to kiss me
on the cheek but my lips were here and
he just goes and we just [ __ ] bump
slap dude
that was great he's so funny he's like a
Joey Diaz yeah which is like just always
it's just always
such a good dude well so not if you
retire so then you're out of the you saw
the pool right Don told him to beat it
that's [ __ ] pain in the ass man peace
right why do you want to go on trt and
[ __ ] no I don't think I'm ready for that
yet right I don't think I mean no
interest no I think eventually I'm gonna
go get checked I'm gonna check it out I
don't feel like I need it yet you know
I'm [ __ ] yeah still feel like uh yeah
back in the old days I mean it wasn't
unheard of her
all the fighters to be doing so yeah
exemption oh yeah yeah I mean yeah it
was the Wild West yeah which one you
heard one guy at a trt exemption like uh
yeah please yeah and then they shut that
down do you think that you shot of stuff
is good or would you would you remove it
I mean
I think it's it's I guess it's good I
mean people if you're gonna cheaters
gonna cheat they're gonna find them yeah
it just makes it harder I guess for them
but uh it's a pain in the ass for us you
know yeah telling these people where we
are at all times like definitely they'll
wake you up at 4am 5am day before 5 a.m
yeah that's most of their problems you
know yeah how do you feel about uh Conor
yeah yeah out of the protocol I mean I
think and he's obviously like obviously
what do you do right he got out of the
protocol I mean listen his [ __ ] leg
was broken half of the dude I mean I get
it you know I do the same [ __ ] you know
he did it he's doing it the right way
kind of he's like all right I'm gonna
get out of the pool not gonna take this
[ __ ] I'm not competing and I'll come
back in yeah you can't blame him unless
he gets the special
exception doesn't have to do to six
months that's where it gets dicey they
let them fight like say in February why
would they give them that because he's
Conor McGregor yeah right and that that
kind of makes it money makes the world
go around so they can make exemptions
and they're like and I I mean I think
the the hard cords will be upset like
MMA media will be upset yeah but the
public is like whatever well he's such a
draw but but you know
it's interesting to see what well I
guess he just has stuff to prove because
he hasn't won a fight I mean no I just
think he likes he likes to beat guy yeah
he's yeah you were supposed to fight him
yeah we came close a couple times that'd
be an interesting
when he fought Mendez I was I was on the
line yeah that fight because he thought
man this could fight dos anjos and then
yeah yeah like two weeks well he'd have
a real problem with your with your
wrestling man a nightmare his boxing is
you know his speed would be a problem
yeah
especially back then a real problem yeah
yeah I mean that would have been [ __ ]
hours even uh later on he said he wanted
to fight me too like yeah but then it
didn't go go through with it
yeah it's so interesting yeah I for him
it's like you know he wants to be the
man obviously fighting's the way he gets
that attention I just think you know
everyone's like oh the money the money
has changed you know obviously if you're
sleeping in Gucci settings man it's
tough to get up and do that yeah
oh I saw you on my Mountain never fight
again but um
you know I just think with his it's not
even I think everyone has an ego with
his ego he's just like I gotta yeah I
can't go out like this no yeah it's part
of his identity and I think he still has
a lot of fight left in him yeah I mean
especially like I feel I wasn't doing
bad against him exactly it was it was
yeah it was bothering him well you think
he lost his pop
I Think It's just tough at the level of
success that he has to make the same
sacrifices that a guy like
um like say if he fought dos Angels like
dos Angels would make even though dos
Angels is older like he's Los Angeles
he moved back to Brazil to train yeah
he's just Savage yeah and he asked
Connor to move you know he's like hell
maybe yeah I'll get off the yacht I'll
see what I can do it's just a different
the sacrifice is just different it's
interesting to speculate on what would
have happened if he hadn't broken his
leg against us and because I think he
looked good but so did Dustin yeah
[ __ ] low leg yeah Dustin's a dog he's
a dog and it's like a Mac Truck Yeah and
he was catching him he was you know
doing he was catching shots and and
answering back with that left hook that
sucks his leg went out like that but but
again that might have been
I don't know I mean sometimes what they
say is that when you when you practice
that a lot so you're checking kicks
you're kicking the bag what they think
is you get these micro fractures if
you're not Wonderboy Thompson's been
doing it forever you get these hairline
fractures which makes your leg really
[ __ ] weak now you kick and somebody
checks it right well I just seen one
where where it was a tie fight and it
got kicked the guy that checked broke
his leg usually it's the other way
around yeah like damn yeah I think we've
got it too like he has long layoffs so
like he's chilling chilling chilling
then he ramps it up for camp where it's
like you really your body is really
being too all the time it's not like
boxing when you guys can take a year off
and then fight these huge fights MMA you
know there's so much to learn in your
body like the blue spin you got to be
ready
the most rugged fighter I think you
could make the argument who just amazes
me is Nate Diaz you can kick that
[ __ ] in the legs 5 000 times you
can punch him in the face he he's like
he's kind of rubbery I think his bones
are like green wood he's just rubbery as
[ __ ] you know what I mean though he
takes these [ __ ] kicks and punches
and he just never you don't check them
or not either refuses to work on it no
he doesn't do wrestling skinny legs
he throws volume that's for sure how do
you feel about the uh like the the Jake
Paul stuff I mean you guys quit me he's
not he's not a YouTuber no more he's a
[ __ ] boxer he's been boxing for five
five years with a great trainer like all
he's doing he's a boxer yeah yeah I mean
I'd like to see him fight a boxer now
yeah you know what if he fought Nate
all right I might think he's too big for
Nate it'd be a problem I mean unless
Nate could could pepper him and wear
them out but I don't know bro and it's a
silver tried winning that fight that's
what I'm saying yeah before they had
some fight I was like oh Jake give me in
some trouble I thought I was fine like
he's out boxing yeah his footwork's good
counter shots he when he dropped him
like let's get the real deal man as far
as possible the level he's at with 16
shots he's a real dick yeah
he wants to do it yeah after that I was
like ooh that's not gonna be easy fight
for anybody yeah and the MMA guys going
into that world especially the older MMA
guys I mean tough tough kids young dude
yeah yeah 26 yeah nuts he doesn't have
all the weirdness I mean he wants to be
a boxer right so he's got to fight a box
or something all right I just don't it's
tough right because
so if I'm Jake and my toughest
competition ever is Anderson Silva It's
My lowest pay-per-view numbers dude [ __ ]
the MMA media quit who cares about
validation from the fight fans like
keep finding KSI the YouTubers
why keep fighting these tough guys so
you know you got six fights everyone's
like find a boxer it's like well who's
he gonna fight though like people I'd
love to see him against Canelo it's like
are you out of your mind I know yes no
six fights Tommy Fury yeah that's the
five I think you start just yeah
I mean Canelo would what about Andrew
Tate though did you see that they scored
him and Andrew I like that one because
they you know world champion cake box
yeah yeah yeah but not a boxer and
there's a big difference yeah it's true
yeah
what's 80 civil right now kicks and
knees and elbows couldn't do none of
that I know true it's a different
distance everything that that would be
interesting he's a big boy he's a big
boy he's not small
but uh
it's just who would have called it you
know what teamwork someone's like hey
you're seeing Logan Paul's little
brother my kids when they were like
[ __ ] a seven and eight we got tickets
to to see Jake Paul went to the Starland
Ballroom and what was he doing like a
performer like yeah are you rapping
rapping and [ __ ] oh wow and the security
guard came up like oh you want your kid
you recognize me kids want to meet him
like yeah [ __ ] him up there he's like
he's like Frank Yeager what's up bro I
used to watch your videos yeah he was
actually medical yeah yeah that's yeah
my even my kid you know because his old
YouTube videos still pop up and tiger
dad you know him like yeah I know is
your friend like we're cool
so you talk to me I've talked hey man
yeah yeah yeah hey man he's a YouTuber
be cool dude you know it's like the kids
celebrities now just different yeah just
different 100 and for your kids like to
to get into fighting your dad's Frankie
Edgar it's like yeah I guess you want to
do it dude like my son says he wants to
find like dude nobody's it's tough for
you that's what I tell you now my my one
he's he and he wrestles [ __ ] six days
a week you know he's all he's all in
he's all wrestling how old is he he's
12. he's 12.
um my 14 year old he wrestle he's
actually football got him into wrestling
against that so uh he just started
playing football two years ago and it
just turned him out you know what I mean
now he's all in on getting better
football and I told his coach Tom
wrestling helps you get better football
so now he wants to wrestle again I'm
like all right better for his head yeah
yeah yeah yeah do you think about CT and
[ __ ] like that everybody does know right
I do man you know so many people talk
about it you can't help you know people
and what's scary what I just heard he's
like you know because I feel like I'm
fine now you know but it [ __ ] comes
on later it comes on later you know I
hit you in the later round yeah yeah
like there's some guys with such a
bummer where you see it like hit while
they're in the USA right right yeah but
then some guys you know I won't mention
names but you know they come on my show
I'm like oh [ __ ] it's okay somebody want
to tell them I guess he's drooling like
somebody want to tell him you know it's
like well you see guys like I mean
whenever you see these boxers like uh
Tommy Hearns and stuff yeah dude it's
like I mean those guys were taking so
much damage though yeah I think boxing
is different no yeah it's it's constant
none of the constant headshots and they
start them when they're young too yeah
really that's the thing when you're like
seven eight you watch these kids sparrow
and they're seven and eight what do you
think about like these Fighters now like
coming up at seven I think this guy
[ __ ] got in UFC 17. 18. look at his
face look at his face yeah like he's got
his nose is already I I look at Aaron
Pico yeah like he'd been boxing since he
was literally nine he was wrestling on
the international certain at 16 and he's
a freak but at the same time I have to
believe that you know when when you take
that much damage image to your head you
you
it you will get a glass jaw what happens
is your your brain shuts off you get
touched your brain's like I've been here
but be the majority of them don't them
maybe not they don't you know what I'm
saying like the majority that kid you
know he's 17. yeah well that's crazy
there's a face of a Spanish no not now
all disrespected like old school like
16th century you may have had a cleft
palate so that may be what we're seeing
so sometimes when when a child has a
cleft palate there's a little bit of a
you see that different I think I'm right
about that you know so it might also be
the way it space is so you know that may
not be but but it looks like that's that
face it looks like he's done a lot of
boxing in his face you know his nose his
nose pretty flat yeah yeah and that's
17. you wanted to like uh will you get
in this this young will guys fight as
long because I mean typically guys got
into UFC after college
and then they fight for a longer time I
think you're getting here I don't know
if you're gonna have the longest career
I don't know yeah yeah the longevity
when you start that young but then again
look at that's important he was fighting
since he was 17. yeah yeah he's yeah
in the UFC yeah yeah right
already arrived at 17 which means he's
been fighting for a long time right no
he doesn't have that many fights Jim
bring him up he's he's young his
experience wise he's young Cory
sandhagen has been fighting since he was
13 I think no he came in the gym at 17.
okay no I think it was 16. I think
Christian Allen found him I think 16.
how young can you fight in the U.S yeah
he started at 17 and then was only doing
Kickback so he only has six fights back
okay so he he started fighting
or amateur two fights 20 20. and I'm
turning 20 and 21 so you know he's new
new yeah yeah you don't have all the
wear and tears but to Frankie's point
you just got one if you start at 17
which this kid is when he's
25 if and he's fighting the UFC yeah the
other thing I think I know the UFC is
the goal and stuff like anything else
yeah skill but you're gonna be fighting
grown men yeah you know that dudes who
are trying to put food on the table they
got to bring him up right you know yeah
but it's tough like like uh it's Warzone
he said it best he's like I tell my guys
like don't come to UFC unless you're
ready to face anybody they offer you and
you can find a way to win whether it's
number one or number 30 you better be
ready to go because you never know who
you're gonna get yeah right and the UFC
isn't a league where they give you
warm-up fight no no it's just not what
they do no when did you kind of did it
Dawn on you that you could be great at
this sport
uh I mean when I when I uh probably when
I got into UFC first fight he was really
yeah first fight you just felt it yeah
you felt at home what was it well I mean
I just know what I want I got to call up
uh
I tried for salesman fighter show didn't
get didn't make it I thought I was gonna
make it too what season is that season
five yeah first uh the first 55 or look
at that reason look at that [ __ ] and uh
I uh
yeah when I I got called up to fight
that and I remember walking in there and
I'm like yeah I I was like you know I
wasn't supposed to win yeah I'm like
[ __ ] oh my God I'm like I know I'm not
supposed to win like but they if they've
been at Sean sharp as a champion in time
I was like if they call me to fight for
sure I was like I'm [ __ ] coming here to
[ __ ] win you know you fought Charles
over there yeah yeah beat him BJ Penn
twice ever heard of him Sean shirk ever
heard of him hermese Franca ever heard
of him Spencer Fisher interesting Tyson
Griffin Jim Miller it's [ __ ] Jim
Miller actually was in Jersey that was
my last fight on a regional scene before
I made it to you oh really yeah that's a
tough region
he kicked a piece of my ear off my head
really yeah Jesus Christ what happened
piece of my cauliflower flew off my ear
and during the fight God look at this
look at this run though Charles Oliveira
BJ Penn Cub Swanson you're my favorite
Chad men's insane and that Jose all the
fight was [ __ ] close
I mean if I'm twice wow yeah
wow he fought the who's too I mean first
ballot Hall of Famer everybody and now
also for you I think you're in a
definitely a different position position
two to retire because I mean you have
plans right like you're already doing a
pot you've been doing a podcast yeah
I've been doing a podcast uh Champion a
[ __ ] for almost three years now and how
do you link up with homeboy he he lives
in Toms River he's actually from Maine
recently Roger Matthews he's my my
co-host he's from Jersey Shore Fame he
used to be Jay Wow's husband ex-husband
now yeah two kids together yeah
um
but yeah he moved down to Jersey back
when he was like 20. we were friends
before we even met uh Matt JWoww and uh
he just became he's like a fake fight
fan that's how he met and I used to
teach like like an informal you know
Jiu-Jitsu more Jersey holy [ __ ] do you
think you regrets that Affliction Church
no no no
that's that's so Jersey you you're fake
you can get your hands manicured
he's getting such a skinny he was like
skinny the skinny dude right from Maine
he's six four he's [ __ ] a big guy you
know [ __ ] skinny he [ __ ] came down Jerry
Jersey seen all seen all the Meatheads
and all the girls so that's when he
started you know he said let's get into
this you know what are you implying he
started eating yeah yeah all right on
your pod does he talk about the Jersey
Shore days he does yeah he does a little
bit Yeah insane that's a big boy yeah
his base he's a big boy
yeah it shows I mean just Game Changer
it was just nuts it was and it's still
it's still right it's still like I can't
popular show on MTV MTV is not really
much on there but Teen Mom and like
Ridiculousness right that's right since
the flagship yeah
but he was on there it was like the
height of it man yeah dude it was like
Seaside Seaside where I live was crazy
it was bananas every summer because
because it is it Jersey Shore yeah it's
a great time in the summer though I used
to go down there what a great time
and by the way I knew I'd been in La for
too long I was hanging out with my
friends all the New Yorkers and from
Jersey and I'd been in La for I don't
know a year Non-Stop and we're down on
the shore
and uh we're at a bar and girls are just
talking to us and I'm such a piece of
[ __ ] because I've been in LA and I'm
going like this I'm going
[ __ ] what's the agenda like who do they
recognize here like what you know I I
couldn't understand why they were
talking about because girls don't talk
to you in La unless there's an agenda
yeah everybody has an agenda men and
women it's all a [ __ ] contract and
they were just human beings saying hi
yeah and I was like I've been [ __ ] up
for too long and you you just love
Jersey you never leave I mean I don't
say I'll never leave because you never
know what happens like hey I'm into it
yeah yeah I mean my whole family's there
you know and do you still work with the
UFC on the UFC gym I do yeah I don't
have my own UFC gym but but I'm an
associated with a couple of them yeah
yeah
you talk to Dana at all I mean I do yeah
yeah it's always good to me you know
yeah oh yeah happy yeah I mean Blood
Sweat and Tears how could you not yeah
you did you kind of did what's almost
impossible I I always said I said Donald
Trump's running too it's like spend that
much time in this Sport and
and win that much and stay that relevant
and be that much of a draw that's a
that's a it's just different it's really
really difficult and rare tough to do
yeah and it's also like a guy like him
he always hated fighting he was like you
know he's secretly wanted to be a comic
Entertainer and stuff like that because
he had to be an athlete his whole life
but for somebody like you do anything
it's a gay man went out and we we're in
love and I want to say that in front of
Frankie and I'm a sugar baby bless us
um
but um it just turns into this
incredibly gay thing we're just like
[ __ ] it yeah I gotta go no Frankie's
like finally yeah yeah kill the cameras
I don't care anymore
but I feel free yeah well anyway I had
something to say but it turned to it and
now it's fine turn into gay fashion as
it always does yeah we've never done a
show after we've done how many episodes
800 3 000.00
851 right now that's not counting the
ones within your garage we've never not
talked about our dicks and we've never
not been gay and this weekend
I took the time to send you nothing but
I just heard I was naked and I go hope
you're having a great day buddy
well no not my dick the [ __ ] picture
God damn it a picture I was very proud
of my dick my wife goes your dick I go
well I got to send I gotta show my boy
what I'm working with good day and I go
there you go I hope you're having a
great day buddy breathing oh and I said
I I did a whole thing I think it was
breathing it was [ __ ] five minutes
later yeah it was like all small really
yeah because my service is bad I was in
Providence in the middle of nowhere I
felt vulnerable because I didn't get a
[ __ ] response from yeah Brian like a
day later goes very quiet like what's up
dude like where the [ __ ] are you I said
you took some time yeah I usually
respond to that anyway we're trying to
come out of the closet wait 800 damn
that's that's that's impressive yeah
more than that it has to be near a
thousand yeah yeah start doing it
literally in my garage yeah almost 11
years ago and then also
I mean and those were the wild west days
and now YouTube wants to get all crazy
crazy
was the first guy to do stuff like sell
merch and kind of like come up with
graphics and I kind of like in a lot of
ways across Market and cross cross
pollinate with podcasts yep Rogan wasn't
doing that you were doing that yeah
people don't realize that everyone
they're out you are so obsessed with
kind of like you know that the merch
drops yeah where you'd like you'd be
like all right post now and that we'd
post like that sold out it's all this
stuff and it worked it was incredible
that's awesome yeah we're struggling a
little bit you know everybody's hottest
yeah I mean you know we were doing it
whatever
like you guys do it once a week once a
week yeah it's in my basement it's not
[ __ ] bad he lives right around the
oldest road so it's not far and uh we
kick it we honestly I I fell into a lot
of good things because of it though I
met a lot of good people I was in a
movie because of it you know you guys
just [ __ ] yeah we just [ __ ] how
you guys do here yeah yeah I bust those
balls for being gay all the time maybe
that's why we're [ __ ] Shadow band
yeah it's a good reason yeah they don't
they frown upon that
well this whole this whole Twitter dump
is really really interesting man
[ __ ] this wild man
whatever it is like if it's a simulation
it's broken you know what I mean because
it's the craziest [ __ ] is going on in
this world yeah it's not good it's
really interesting yeah I'm curious
because it's the s'mores can keep coming
out and you see these big corporations
were suppressing news but they're also
making Elon Musk the boogeyman it's like
what are you doing he's he's a guy who
creates more jobs than you do
[ __ ] he he pays more in taxes
than any than any of you your entire
Newsroom yeah based on like it because
they don't you can't control it makes
American cars like you know yeah they
hate that he's gonna buy Twitter and he
believes him and he believes in a free
[ __ ] speech and no hate speech has
actually not gone up people keep saying
that no there's no evidence to suggest
that but that's what the left hand yeah
but when the media does that they just
keep losing credibility so you keep
saying the world's this way but the rest
of us know I don't believe anything like
nothing like unless I steal my own eyes
I don't think I believe it but that's
not if I believe anything in the past
either now
we have bright special on the podcast oh
yeah Bryce son yeah that definitely got
your flashlight oh yeah yeah I've had a
model that's a little move yeah yeah
he's all flat Earth and stuff well
that's something you're talking about
flutters yeah with you yeah and was this
before because we challenged Rogan this
is right after the challenge where do
you studying astrophysics
I mean my reasons why I think the world
is round or not that you're tired
Mitchell who's an MMA fighter and uh at
23 years old has decided contrary to
everyone else in the Science World I'm
waiting I'm around Earth all right I'm
with you but and my thing is like the
sun's round the [ __ ] Moon's around
you could see Mars in a telescope around
why would they why would why would you
be flat there are really simple ways
there's also there's like experiments
you could do right just a couple yeah
have you ever have you ever seen that
yeah we fly hold on you know we you know
you know flight patterns yeah yeah we
take into account the culture of the
earth I say that's why we fly over the
Arctic I don't snipers have to take the
curvature I had I had David Weiss who
was on I he's a flat Arthur like and he
had all these little experiments then
his science has brought him on it was so
fun though because he was beating me in
the argument it was great like the part
of the thing was he was so ready with
his diagrams and I got crushed in the
argument that's always done but that's
all they do but that's fun yeah I liked
it and it was part of the entertainment
but don't get it it twisted and I said
so explain to me how flight patterns
because I have friends that are pilots
you take into account the curvature and
your flight pattern so that way and he
goes a lot of Pilots to speak it out now
I go really and there's an ice there's
an ice shop right there where is that
actually and what's beyond the ice shelf
and he goes we don't know we don't well
that doesn't work this is very
interesting the whole thing there's a
flat Earth there on uh you got made
world star what I mean months ago and
he's like I'm gonna prove that the Earth
is flat except this thing's like you can
tell when the sun only goes up and down
or something like so he sets this whole
thing up he's explaining it and then the
the sun comes up and you can see like
the Horizon it's rounded and he goes ah
[ __ ]
well did I get this whole presence
about the laser and he just side steps
because they did an experiment where you
can shoot a laser straight for a long
distance and if you have everything on
the same side it'll you yeah and he was
like yeah that day he went it didn't
that didn't work or that was a I was
like okay so Bryce says the sun and the
moon are the same size he should Bryce
Bryce should counterparts yeah Bryce
should Bryce should speak to a real
scientist and educate himself a little
bit oh we're going to speak to a
physicist or not what they do though is
they say all of them are liars and NASA
is all liars NASA by the way well this
is true though what's that that's not no
no well yeah it was a fact yeah but the
whole any picture of the world is not
real that's CJ eyed any whole picture of
the world yeah I've heard that that's in
there
team round I'm team round I'm just
saying yeah but I go when they're in the
eyes the the International Space Station
and these astronauts you could go to
[ __ ] Instagram probably yeah take
they take pictures from from that you
can see the curvature of the earth yes
you can feel like you know yes no we're
Team round here yeah yeah
yeah oh man it's horror
yeah it is interesting It's just tough
because let's say you are a flat earther
and then you see what the media is doing
with the hunter Biden stuff and like
suppressing that right or other things
like now we find out Christopher
Columbus didn't discover America but we
grew up in the literature that you were
reading all these books from Christopher
Columbus now he's out well Christopher
Columbus is it's a controversial thing
to say he discovered yeah the whole
Christopher Columbus thing listen like
he was a good guy was not a good guy
like oh this guy got on a [ __ ] boat
was trying to sell to China he had to be
crazy crazy as hell boy he's a wild boy
but you know you find out like all this
stuff you can't really believe it or you
know with chopping down the the apple
tree with George White like found out
all this stuff right right and so so
then all they go is well if and this is
what gives them credit to go well if
that's not true this isn't true it's
like well no can't be all fake I've
always equated to this if if I went up
to Bryce Mitchell and yourself and you
and I said said hey guys I know you do
this MMA [ __ ] okay I can show you right
now video of people flying through the
air
flying and doing sidekicks
it's called Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon that [ __ ] is based on real stuff
and I was dead serious and I showed you
video of Shaolin Monks doing all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] including Aikido experts
throwing you with with weights I would
believe and you guys would go hey you
don't fight [ __ ] you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about come to my
gym and see what happens the problem is
that people who are flat earthers are
not going to NASA they're not around
scientists they would very quickly
realize with simple experiments they
would change their mind immediately with
simple experiments I'm not even looking
at the sky there are just certain simple
experiments there are certain scientific
principles that by the way
all the technology you use in this phone
is based on the same principles so we we
benefit guys all of us benefit from the
science of this microphone in this in
that TV that pushes you beyond your
biology when you get an x-ray when you
have to when you have staff and you have
to take antibiotics that is part of the
same scientific tradition the same
empirical measurable process that will
also prove to you that gravity is real
the Earth is round it's moving at two
thousand miles an hour and all those
things you don't got to convince me I
know but that's what I'm saying is like
you know you've got to be a little bit
more consistent these are some some but
also sometimes because the conspiracies
are better than the truth there are a
lot that's why it's fun for them to like
go get a good game talk about them
and some of them are true some of them
are true that's where that's where
you're like okay that's what makes every
conspiracy kind of interesting
we all knew there was some [ __ ] going on
at Twitter right we all know that if you
if you are
middle of the road right of Center or if
you just believe in the Constitution you
can there's a good chance you if you're
asking asking questions about covet just
asking you'd get censored we'll forget
to it I mean yeah of course Twitter
Youtube Instagram oh yeah it's all owned
by the same or it's run by people of a
specific yes ideological careful being
don't cognate yourself now I don't care
about it no no I'm not saying I'm not
saying juice
no I'm saying it's it's a it's a group
of people that come from the same
educational system same area code same
yeah right you know they all people in
newsrooms Academia Hollywood they're all
the the the people are all kind of like
the ink around yeah yeah soft but you
see like the the news where they're
saying the same exact [ __ ] across like
it's all national news like literally
the same line well it's like no wonder
some people think the Earth is flat yeah
right you look at that you're like this
is insane I get it
I get it
I don't mean to pick on Bryce Mitchell
you know he's he's just a he's just the
most visited he's fighting this weekend
too I think yeah he's a killer he is
what's your what's your take on on him
what's it where's he's got his work cut
out for him like anybody in that weight
class but yeah I'm a tough weight but I
mean but he did the answer man that was
impressive to me super impressed
especially on the feet yeah
he started wrestling he was arrested I
think so but yeah he mixes up pretty
well you're a fan of Patty pimlet I he's
just fun you know it's just so fun yeah
I know I know Jared Gordon pretty well
too so
he uh he's a New York guy and who do you
have in these fights and for and for uh
Patty I think you know with him
obviously Super Famous he's so famous in
uh Europe so [ __ ] famous
saying he's bigger than cop is that
right yeah yeah and uh I think the UFC
is doing right by him with like the way
they're kind of slowly building up
because the guy underneath them they
push too fast yeah yeah right right with
Woodley right Jaron Gore is not a bit
tough fight for pretty tuck he could
grab on stuff he could wrestle a little
bit I mean he's uh he's a brown belt
under John Dana yeah a brown boner
John's Well black belt in most places
watch your ankles so so for Patty you
know he's not gonna have a huge
advantage on the ground but I don't know
there's something special about Patty
when you're around like this kid gots it
hey yeah but it's not an easy fight no
no not an easy fight for dinner too he's
a big 55 yeah and Gordon's not that big
I don't think oh yeah he's kind of a
little bit smaller for tilt too it's
like this ain't no welcome home party
like that duplicity I I can't remember
he's a former Champion other uh leagues
like he's he's a pretty Striker man
um oh Jesus yeah okay his his
submissions are good he was the EFC uh
Champion he was a ksw champion like he's
chomping out the pit in this fight like
this is the fight where is he from
is he a Polish what is he South African
yeah South African yeah
but he's a he is no punk middle and
Walter and Darren's Hill's coming off an
injury right coming off the injury
hasn't fought since 2019. ah Frank
Franklin when you you know you're
fighting a guy let's say a dagestani or
someone who um has a different kind of
he has had a win since 2019. he fought
Derek Benson Robert Whittaker and then
uh his last win against Kelvin got some
Split Decision too in 2019. when when
you have a fight with a guy who say is
uh like to say a dagestani who's coming
at you with a different kind of language
like a different kind of wrestling chain
wrestling that you maybe haven't seen
with freestyler or with you know folk
wrestling and stuff do you bring guys in
how do you guys solve that problem yeah
you try to bring guys to emulate guys
early in my career I used to bring guys
in all time I mean I had geishi uh
Poirier RDA
um Evan Dunham I then add some barbozo I
brought them today they once once they
they kind of came once they came I need
to Ed said Marlon Eddie so I didn't have
to bring you guys in but yeah you got to
bring people in you didn't suck weight
the way a lot of guys did 55 or not I
mean I probably was I remember my first
fighting UFC on the way to Wayne's I
stopped and got a Cheesesteak so I
wouldn't be that small oh damn yeah you
felt good that's such confidence though
have that that's a lot of confidence I
mean there was no other way to fight 55
was the lightest way
right yeah
you know the 45 35
you know you know yeah 25 25 I came
later yeah
yeah small guys
they're doing the damn thing you know
the UFC's popping man with 27 uh uh sold
out events in a row or something like
that that's crazy Endeavor just just did
like 38 increase in in their profits in
the fourth quarter so they make they're
not off live shows they said their
biggest thing is ESPN or UFC and uh PBR
I guess yeah PBR yeah they own PBR
that's right yeah they just took over
though because hey I remember that four
billion dollar note was a big note to
carry people like they're gonna never be
able to do it but but now now it's worth
more yeah
oh yeah
it's a world it's a true worldwide sport
we've watched it become yeah when you
walk around have you gone to other
countries where you just get you must
get noticed definitely definitely do I
was in Germany uh two weeks ago that day
for UFC Gym opening out there oh really
their fan base is not as big as other
places they haven't really had any
Germans yeah you need a German fighter
who's the most famous person you've been
recognized by
oh I don't I don't know [ __ ] I remember
right what was it I mean I met Kevin
James once ago I'm a fan I'm like you're
fat but I'm a fan yeah because there are
a lot of people I say Jake Paul
there are a lot of movies it's like
actors that love Fighters so I feel like
yeah
Mickey Road
sometimes that's pretty cool yeah yeah
he's cool he's different dude he is yeah
he got his Lids done he got his Lids
done
and some and he got some other stuff
they were saying like Rogan was talking
about him when he did the wrestler like
how'd you get muscular Muscular like
that he goes I took everything I was
taking all the drugs yeah he's like oh
[ __ ] but his character was too good in
that movie oh yeah oh yeah Sam Drew we
said he was any comic Who's down the
road that movie depresses you because
he's like it's pretty towns I love that
movie bro that's how I was at this
wrestling event it wasn't WWE you know
and I always just said like if I go
through signings I'm like man what the
[ __ ] you'll see fans like WWE fans what
the hell no we're not our fans are are
even better yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
levels oh man there's levels
very strange if you've ever gotten a
Monster Jam it's like they did a calling
like hey ugliest people in Southern
California come to Monster Jam I saw
like Confederate flags
just you know just yeah Florida is like
that like you can if you can go to like
Miami you can go to Naples but if you
step outside something if you go like 30
minutes that way sometimes you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on here it's like
alligator Central yeah hottest girl has
three teeth oh yeah it's hard it gets
weird in Florida I broke up a fight uh
when I was in Florida actually I mean I
mean like it was two old guys one girl
fighting two girls
and one girl walks by we're sitting here
at Virginia our boy Eric the restaurant
vergina yeah [ __ ] the best so you're
sitting there yeah and Eric opens up
these crazy wines we're eating Stone oh
crap [ __ ] hang him after the show
laughing and it's great and this these
two
um
they were uh well her skirt was
well I could see everything her skirt
you know if she was just she'd she'd
been
she had some bruises on her legs from
from the pole she was a rough in Naples
yes sir in that area correct sir but it
was late so they were walking they were
all they're looking for some old guys
yeah that's what happens that's where
the money is have you been in Naples
like an older town uh uh Sarasota area
you'd have the most color there so the
girl there's a girl she's with these two
kind of young guys and she says
something like look at these two skanks
old school and the girl turns and goes
I'll deep throat your [ __ ] right now
[ __ ] I'll deep throat it that's
your girlfriend I'll deep throat your
[ __ ] so we're eating we're like she's
saying all [ __ ] right in front of
us right here and we're like well
those fighting words I mean I'd be like
well now the two girls come back because
the other goes [ __ ] you and there's
words so now we're like
oh that looks like a situation yeah
the next thing you know Bam Bam this one
girl's fighting two girls and they're
going and the one girl starts winging
but the oh the the girls I I the girls
who had said I'll deep throat your [ __ ]
they were the aggressors they came back
the yeah and they they kind of they
began to fight yeah this girl yeah this
girl this girl gave it back and when I
tell you she was throwing well she was
going but like throwing like straight
punches and catching you could just hear
it
yeah like in the base I I swear to God
ask Kevin Mac he was there there was a
she'd rather and just uppercut she went
no she had the girl got her hair pulled
and she was she was getting her hair
pulled and she went boom I started
Francis ingano uppercut yeah and I'm
trying to stop the whole [ __ ] thing
and I at one point the girl I was
holding on to I go let go of her [ __ ]
hair and she wouldn't let go of her hair
as I'm kind of like that's the worst
thing about a girl fights
I can't hurt anybody so I'm trying to
like get her out by twisting I'm just
like let go and my my other buddy is
holding onto the girl's hair so it
doesn't get crazy so is the single girl
winning the single girl
was winning Not only was did she win
throat twins got beat up she won the
deep throat twins get pushed we pushed
the wheel get go go over there yeah and
the girl who was there goes I got your
[ __ ] hair I got your hair in my hands
[ __ ] I [ __ ] you up wow she was such
a badass did she look like uh they're
all looking I'm gonna be honest with you
I'm an old man they all look pretty good
yeah
yeah the girls were probably wow I don't
want to say anything they're night
Walkers and the cops the cop came over
that we all knew and he just goes you
walk that way you walk that way and
that's it that's how he is yeah you're
right but meanwhile Kevin got kicked in
the shin so hard to heal yeah he was
like [ __ ] he literally was like this
[ __ ] I was like that's what you get how
aggressive is I will deep throat I'd be
like I hadn't seen a girl fight like
that in a while they were sweet
girlfriends in high school yeah well I
assume on Worldstar all the time he's
such a fan but I like world star because
it's black girls so they have the wig so
when they go to grab the hair right off
dude it's just it's just these qualities
these were Florida white girls and
they were they were rough night Walkers
man I will deep throat it was it was so
aggressive by the way a little hot
that's what I was like
hey all the guys were like I mean not a
bad looking woman because they're like
rough but you know she she was so how
much yeah yeah she had a face like
Frankie anger you know I spotted but a
nice body
um yeah it was it was a couple Maple
Rascals a couple Naples Rascals they
were coming out of town yeah they're not
from there looking for sugar daddy
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
that yeah that all goes on there yeah
hey I don't judge there's nothing but oh
you would have loved it there was a they
had a Porsche
display really yeah dude just all these
horses
all that [ __ ] yeah they were looking for
old guys did they not find them hey I
was there with my wife [ __ ] off I'm a
young man I got my Lids done when they
were fighting with your girl like oh by
the way but I am old I I I like you this
is what you realize you get older at my
eyes don't look at girls in their 20s
because there's a good chance they're
gonna be like get away from me
but I'm the guy I'm I am that guy this
girl was with my buddy and she goes she
goes I go who's better looking joking
around she goes well you're the guy who
would pay my bills and he's the guy I'd
have sex God bless her I was like that
hurts my feelings but I get it I get it
and I showed her the video I sent you
and then she yelled at you I will deep
throat your [ __ ] yeah that was so
aggressive only a guy would be like
him guys are like I'm like this is cool
wow
what an aggressive statement he was so
aggressive he got beat up
you got girl fights are Savage I mean
even even like when you watch them on
UFC it's like girls are just tougher man
yeah they're mean they're mean have you
been in any street fights since you've
been a professional fighter no not well
since I've been USC now no have you ever
had anybody start [ __ ] with you not
since I've been UFC it's not Jersey yeah
that was Frankie well you're too famous
you know I'm always with people too yeah
and other Fighters probably yeah a lot
to feel like your boy from Jersey Shore
might have more problems right uh I'm
not anymore no I still go out he does a
little bit and he's half single I bet
he's fun to go out with yeah he he's
he's he uh
he's like you know he
he's all he's like 47. you know wow
that's good he's 47 he married Jenny
late late in his greatest kids at 40. so
he lived like a single life till he was
like 40. I ran it I wrote it I ran it
hard yeah
all right
she's pretty
yeah a lot those people those kids
options are sure make serious money yeah
yeah he has like nine bucks look at
Frankie is that your wife yes my wife
that's awesome was that Halloween this
was a Halloween yeah he's like no it's
just a Tuesday you've been married a
long time right Frank I've been married
since
2008. damn bro good job yeah that's
impressive a hot second hot second is
right
and would you hang out with any of the
other Jersey Shore members um I know the
situation
a little bit uh uh Snooki we know
something they they uh they have a house
down the shore so we'll run to them her
husband wrestled oh he did yeah yeah
you guys uh
it's looking interesting though
yeah
some I don't know some Halloween party
in Vegas actually I think it was that's
[ __ ] and you guys were gangsters yeah
all right
all right not that crazy stuff let's see
bless you excuse me bless you I can't
get over I will deep throat your [ __ ] to
another lady it was unbelievable by the
way it's 10 p.m here PST so late thank
you so much Frankie for coming out yeah
man seriously this is fun uh so there's
a studio a tattoo studio that's offering
to remove Kanye West tattoos from people
for free right and it costs it can cost
up to like 3 800 bucks or four thousand
dollars and it hurts worse than getting
tattoos it's probably yeah and it takes
a lot of sessions what did they say yeah
multiple sessions 10 or 12 sessions yeah
it's not like in the skin has to heal so
it takes forever
yeah but they're doing it for free but
also if you got Kanye West tattoo on
your arm just stick with it yeah yeah
right geez yeah you got it for a reason
so stick with it yeah like I was saying
like it's just tight like about Kevin
Spacey tattoo yeah well no it's not the
same it's not the same it's like it's
weird if you're gonna say Hitler there
were good things about Hitler it's like
look if I'm a good golfer but I [ __ ]
goats
you're not gonna really talk about my
golf
that might be true I'm really a Tiger
Woods very good thought well that's like
Bill Burr's joke he's like look if
Michael Jackson had sex with kids we
still have to come to terms with the
fact that he wrote Thriller
he says some slappers yeah
why do people hang on every word this
guy says like he's obviously yeah don't
give him a platforms
he's covering his entire face yeah yeah
dude I've showed my wife she's like
that's not him I'm like what do you mean
that's not him yeah his problem too it's
like if he would have said Hitler did
some good things obviously Hitler did
atrocious things but if he should have
done the anti-semitic thing and then
said Hitler's done good things you can't
do that but if he was just a normal dude
and said you know Hitler uh you know the
auto body came up with highways
they give him credit for it like he has
a lot of things like with his inventions
a lot of stuff that he did but so that's
all he's referring to it's like hey
dumbass you know he can't be
anti-semitic and then highlight Hitler
correct well look yeah I mean yeah
this
yeah there are a lot of reasons it's
come when you kill six million people
yeah oh yeah actually more than one and
started a World War and the all the
Russians yeah he's the devil yeah he's
the worst you don't get Wicked I don't
think it gets worse than it's not like
when you say nobody has ever said well
he's actually worse than Hitler is he
how many people you've never heard that
yeah no yeah Stalin Stalin was strong
Stalin was a nice guy
all right so um I saw this on Rogan's IG
that San Francisco
they voted to allow police to use deadly
force with robots
right they can't stop you from stealing
from Rite Aid though right that sucks so
bad so that's the robot
that's like a stock photo probably but
they're they're saying like they could
use deadly force with a robot instead of
having to be there personally to shoot
we already do those drones yeah we do or
no but at least drones is man controlled
these are these are these are the same
they're gonna have first of all that's
what Boston Dynamics is about you've
seen that mechanical dog right yeah
you're gonna have it looks crazy they
can get anywhere it wants flip an inch
have you seen that yeah they look crazy
have you guys seen RoboCop exactly yeah
you've never seen iRobot but the robot
have you seen the robot have you seen
the the robot that can dance yeah you've
seen that [ __ ] I mean yeah
it kind of looks fake too sometimes yeah
I've heard some of that yeah but then
also hey San Francisco just worry about
picking up the human [ __ ] on the floor
instead of these robots with crime I get
tougher on crime so people just don't
have a free-for-all up there
it is interesting though like a robot
the members of the board voted eight to
three in support of the policy which
we'll need to pass another vote by the
board on December 6.
from what I understand from people who
live there and are in law enforcement
that board doesn't even have a Democrat
on it they they're all socialists and
Communists and it's very interesting to
me that they would want enforcement by a
robot there's something anti-human about
that well robot doesn't see color Brian
yeah but there's somebody who has to be
operating the robot doesn't it sound
that's an Asian facial with facial
recognition that's probably gonna be an
Asian fella
right I'm not even responding to that
because I didn't speak English think
what Brendan's saying hey Kanye
[Laughter]
I will deep throat your dick
okay what a threat like classic I bet
you can't I doubt you can can you prove
it right then her man's like I guess
I'll do this I mean I'd be like just let
her let her get back at me it's fine
I'll be like yeah I'd be like baby
believe this [ __ ] I mean let's see it
right yeah
do you remember a co-pilot that was a
suddenly somehow exited the plane and
died no I don't remember this so he
jumped out of the plane that's okay
since that was a assumption before they
had no idea he was murdered no so there
was an investigation that happened
apparently
he got sick and then he wanted to like
get to the back area of the plane and
this is a plane where parachute jumpers
go off okay so there's a ramp it's open
so apparently he probably like walked
out and just got sucked out of the place
that's turbulence yeah you probably just
wasn't feeling good I was like you know
what man let me uh just get some fresh
air yeah he actually threw up oh yeah
I'm gonna throw in the coffee he threw
up in the cockpit but he he walked
outside and then got sucked out the
toxicology report sure that Crooks was
tested for amphetamines cocaine yeah
nothing oh he's fine yeah he just walked
out of the back of the plane and got
sucked out because of turbulence and you
know the suction oh what a awful and
that that death is that's got to be the
worst oh you just Fallen dude that's got
to be the worst so he's got one of the
worst
you think you fall you die when you fall
or you think like like on the way down
uh that's a very [ __ ] good question
because they said the people that I
believe you you're alive the whole time
well they said the people in uh 911 I
don't know how they can confirm this but
Ireland people are so hot they're like
either burned alive or jumped they said
a lot of people that jump their bodied
some mechanism your body shut everything
down so they were dead like they were
not conscious yeah I mean I'd imagine
you know you're gonna it I mean I mean
oh you know it's not demand well but
there are better ways to die I got
buddies that Skydive they say you know
the Pirates people bounce like you
bounce off the ground Jesus Christ yes
I've heard that yeah damn
I skydived when I was 17. I used a fake
ID to go Jesus Christ yeah and I did it
didn't do a tandem either I took a class
and did it myself
I would never do it and I'm too big to
do it so I can't have like the guy on my
back I would have to learn yeah I'm not
doing it yeah I'm doing 250. yeah I
think I think it's 245 yeah
you just have some big dude or some that
was my thing I think when I was like I
don't know if this guy's having a bad
day everybody wants to take me with him
you know exactly yeah I feel that way I
feel like we want to jump on [ __ ]
Spirit Airlines Southwest
so these guys hating us dude I was
pretty good so I went with my my coach
my wrestling coach he was probably 29 I
was 17. and he has like over a thousand
jumps we went down to the Drop Zone he
was staying the whole day and um we were
staying that night doing 10 and [ __ ] and
I took the whole class with a bunch of
adults and I look like I'm 17 I was like
I'm [ __ ] 15 probably yeah and they
think I'm 20 something years old because
of my ID
so it ended a class we're about to jump
they said the wind's too high you can't
jump today so we could either do tandem
or you wait tomorrow and I'm like I
[ __ ] took six hour class I'm like I'm
here I'll wait till tomorrow so everyone
else they were they weren't staying so
they jumped and all these older people
like dude you should maybe just do a
tandem do it then I'm like [ __ ] that
so then that night we went out we go to
some bar with these guys and uh one with
my buddy Steve my coach and they all
just were drinking getting you know
tuned up and eating and he goes to the
bathroom they're all jumping the car
like Paul let's go we're leaving I'm
like what the [ __ ] at the back of the
Drop Zone they left Steve there playing
a joke on him and I'm sitting in a
Winnebago with a bunch of hippies you
know and they're [ __ ] passing the
ball around they're like why Drake and
drive when you could smoke and fly I'm
like
man I got up the next morning and jumped
out the plane
yeah oh hell no and did you love it I
mean it was cool it was quite he had
like piping on your suit it's like when
I jumped out the guys are
essentially taking your first course you
know first test yeah so these guys are
kind of holding on to me they're jumping
with me yeah they'll jump out the same
time he's giving me like the hand
signals to like you know check them out
timing her check this check that and
then my buddy comes coming up with the
camera and he's like you know I'm just
like [ __ ] like ah and he's hit me
with the pull sign and I believe him
paying attention he takes my hand just
pulls pulls the things [ __ ] I'm like
holy [ __ ] you know what you're really
it's not jumping if you gotta fly the
parachute after yeah you do yeah you
can't just fall down yeah the radio what
you're talking about yeah yeah the radio
yeah you need that have you you've done
it yeah I have no desire to do it I was
scared it's like Pro
all right hold on let's see some work
stuff
all right Marcus
uh all right this is a continuing
conversation from things we've talked
about but you know as
more research happens smartphone
addiction linked with lower cognitive
abilities less self-control and worse
psychological well-being barely has any
likes
people on social media are like gay keep
scrolling I know yeah it's a heart
message as I post this from my
smartphone look these devices are not
going away if anything they're becoming
more ingrained in our day-to-day how do
we guard against these detrimental
consequences for ourselves and our kids
I have some ideas but would like to hear
yours
help and fly a message like this post
not turning lights comments uh
sharing your story I mean what do you
want me to do everyone's gonna look at
on their phone so just ads we'll we'll
figure it out we'll figure this out the
way we figured TV out but we figured
everything out think so I don't know I
think human beings
this is Brian another figure yeah we'll
figure it out oh no no you have a
problem I don't accidentally shot dead
by his own dog that stepped on the
trigger of the loaded
[Music]
yeah so I guess okay wow you're getting
too much dark stuff but
so the dogs yeah they go hunting he lays
his rifle down at the bed of the truck
apparently and the dog must have stepped
on the trigger of the gun and shot him
and his his buddies rushed him to the
hospital
that's depressing it does I mean that's
some I mean I don't know
I don't think the dog you know what kind
of dog that is I mean that's like a bad
uh gun
etiquette no leave your [ __ ] gun on
the ground jumping around you know yeah
with the his stuff you don't assume your
dog's gonna pull the trigger knows what
kind of dog that is I don't know English
Setter is it yeah no no I know what it
is it's a murderer all right it's a
murdering [ __ ] dog that should kill
her [ __ ] dude
why'd you poke my dick
all right Evan Rachel was girlfriend
nice coursing woman to accuse me Romance
of assault
so I don't know if you guys have been
paying attention to this but it's one of
these things after the Amber Heard
joined up trial where
she releases this big documentary
accusing me Romance of all these
different things
and as
Marilyn Manson has finally filed this
extensive lawsuit because he's been
pretty mom on it he hasn't done yeah he
got it all together and then released
you know like filed this lawsuit
and it looks like this woman ill
mcgorlick I've been reading more about
her and is that her on the right no
that's that's something she's
fine I was just watching for her bad for
him right look at that picture
there's some uh I think she's an
interesting points to it where they they
go she's recruiting girls to like you
know possibly coercively act just like
girls come to you it's like go out and
find girls
for him that's one element of it like or
finding girls to testify or say oh yeah
I'll say that he did
maybe one on one date with him say this
you know to make it seem worse yeah the
discovery uh she's like he was really
into Satan it's like yeah uh it's
Marilyn Manson I mean I've heard things
like buying a pitbull but like this
thing right yeah so it's it's some
interesting things are coming out
because it look if you watch the
documentary it's like oh obviously he's
guilt like they made it seem so clear
um but she's uh also look at him man
he's a vampire and Elma Gordon seems
like one of these people like she'll get
a hold of somebody like Evan Rachel Wood
and like planted in her mind and I guess
she kind of has a history of scamming
people this movie
you from where do I know her from she
was in Westworld yeah Westworld
go to her uh I know somebody who uh
worked with her yeah what'd you say or
would they say I got stories but I'll
keep it to myself
where do I know her from Tim she's a
hell of an actor oh True Blood oh True
Blood she's a hell of an actress what
was she True Blood though wishing True
Blood IMDb
oh look activist actus actress activist
okay that's just like a yeah
yeah where am I think I've seen them
recently what have I seen Frozen dude no
voice here she's had a good career
but keep going down
no I don't know any of these
robots I guess True Blood maybe yeah
yeah somebody was kind of saying online
somebody who has an expertise in this
kind of stuff that her dad seems to have
NPD she was possibly molested as a child
like this is speculation but she's like
she behaves consistently with these
things and kind of laid out this theory
for like how people deal with the shame
of sex after relationship you know with
Marilyn Manson yeah or their or their
manipulative bad people who are about
themselves I'm not saying that's the
case but I do know I have heard things
yeah from what I think what I consider
reliable sources but I'm not I'm not
going to go into it because
um
it just doesn't matter but but either
way I think when I see that stuff I'm
always I do have skeptical hippo eyes
especially when people frame themselves
as not having any agency it's like this
years-long relationship and it's like so
you took no part in this yeah everything
yeah that's right and that's how that
woman is tough chick you know she's a
right and Marilyn Manson too he's kind
of quiet the whole thing man what's
going on you just see all these things
you've happened like well you can't do
anything well no he was waiting bill in
the case he launched something I forget
what exactly did but him and his uh
defense team launched something and it's
gonna get pretty dicey oh really and
then also people I don't know if the
majority he's also legit genius like
he's like yeah oh he's [ __ ] smarter
he's a genius yes legit genius yes he's
a legit but but uh uh I'll uh help you
out with the rumor mill there a lot of
people thought he was the best friend
from Wonder Years and he's not there you
go so many rumors so so now he is saying
that she got this one scam that's simply
one of many accusations where he's like
they they tried to hack into my phone to
like send text messages like from my
phone or account so like they could see
these the messages between Emma Gore and
Evan Rachel would like basically
conspiring behind the scenes innocence
to frame him there's all these different
charges defamation's only one of them
because they wanted to make it like
anti-slap proofs it wouldn't get thrown
yeah well that's so so just so you know
if you try to sue somebody for making an
allegation about you it won't even in
California it won't go anywhere it's
called a slot motion it's like they're
just telling their story you can't sue
somebody for telling it's the First
Amendment which I actually agree with
ultimately you know you have to kind of
agree with that but you're not able to
it'll cost you and then what happens is
if you sue somebody for making an
allegation against you or a bunch of
people yeah the the you when when you
get hit with the slot motion and the
judge throws it out you're paying their
legal fees so I hope you have a million
dollars yeah yeah yeah and um
they designed it with that in mind
there's a number of different
accusations like that illmagor like
swatted Marilyn Manson's house and wow I
was watching this lawyer review it you
know I used to be like oh my God like
there's so many things you sent that to
me I want to watch yes yeah
um yeah he's an interesting dude
look at uh uh what's his name Bostwick
uh I can't remember his name uh Alistair
um look Verizon reporter who who
dissected the Woody Allen case
and when you watch that [ __ ] dude you're
like oh [ __ ] he's not guilty Woody Allen
with his stepdaughter not guilty at all
if you look at that [ __ ] at the
actual court records it's that's why two
investigations they were like and then
they were like there's nothing here I
mean it was just creepy she's the one
well did he not marry his stepdaughter
yeah but when he met him he was old and
now he met her when she was a grad
student right he didn't know her when
she was a kid it's not true he had met
her once or something
when she was a grad student yeah but he
was already estranged from his wife but
like Marilyn Manson it makes it because
of stuff like that where it's like oh
he's creepy therefore do we also believe
that he's a well Woody Allison great
director with Marilyn Manson's like he's
you know biting heads up look at that
[ __ ] Winklevoss twins owed 900 million
dollars by crypto broker wow they're
probably never going to see that these
guys keep taking else huh yeah but why
is this guy in jail they keep falling
huh he gave a billion dollars to
democratic uh
right yeah why is he's not in jail he's
not even like no one's fault no they're
not doing anything they're paying him to
speak at events amazing this is it this
is a different
um it's not FTX but a lot of these
places I think have you know because of
the price crashes or other things Ripple
effects from the FTX collapse I guess
that's what it is but
you know it's hard to feel good for them
obviously they winklevance is just I
mean they take some else obviously they
have an issue with their agreements with
Facebook but they keep making bad yeah
yeah and they and they should get a
Bitcoin for a super long like I remember
when it first went up to like 20K or
something they were like worth a billion
dollars like because of that you know so
it's like you know the Winklevoss twins
in uh what's that movie no oh the
network the network Yeah by Army Hammer
they also are accountables
uh twins accused of cheating on exam
when 1.5 million lawsuit yes this is an
interesting one like
these girls I guess were sitting five
feet apart their identical twins
um studying at Southern Carolina Medical
School
and
they were like taking an exam sitting
four or five feet apart and
uh uh
a few weeks later school officials
accused him of cheating it became a
whole ordeal they were freaking out
um obviously they weren't doing that but
it's a it's a weird thing that you have
to
you know fight your way back from
wait so are they cheating or no no they
were I mean they use that weird Twin
power oh I don't trust them redhead
don't trust them right they believe they
were signaling like by like nodding in
unison or like doing like things like
twins
I think you're rushing the judge get
them out of here you're being a little
superficial get them out of here we're
just nodding at questions get out of
here Reds there was no signaling oh
you're just nodding at questions
twin telepathy dude I told you
but I mean but that is a thing
kind of like we have
look at the cheaters
and they were like any part of his case
was like they have really similar grades
it's like well they're twins
but yeah this is a series of uh
behaviors that looked suspicious
to the evil villain in this story
so I don't know if you guys have been
keeping up with this I saw a poster that
was like I ran has finally banned the
morality you know but I guess not
yeah of course not par for the course
authoritarian regime's uh lying yeah to
the public
uh yeah it's all late well yeah sorry
everybody it's kind of quiet here the
world's leading for a few hours I'm
trying to see yeah Brian has to take
your flight in 30 minutes uh oh let's go
then the world no we'll finish on it
let's do one more after this obviously
but there's so they said it's fake news
they spread that this was so they're
still yeah the truth is that reigning
women are still subject to the
oppression of a radical theocracy yada
yada wait I got one for us they're
strict how about these three crypto
billionaires in their 20s and 30s just
[ __ ] die yeah they're diamond yeah
and then he's dead the next day and then
the younger kid drowns in like a Laker
pool had his wallet keys everything on
them how interesting and another guy
died in his sleep I mean I you know come
on oh you think the Earth is round I
mean there's some [ __ ] going on but I'm
like what why are they yeah because
people lost a lot of money and maybe the
wrong people lost a lot of money
gangsters I don't know man but were
these people part of the FTX thing uh I
don't know
is this with the demise of it
yeah
one guy died you know these three
gentlemen have the toughest names in the
world yeah stripped of his license in
Russia in 2018 for allegedly ripping off
investors yeah you [ __ ] with Russians
and those gangsters are going to [ __ ]
kill you
uh yeah that's not gonna be good yeah
you're not gonna strip his license yeah
that's not good they'll get you they'll
get you
made many on Twitter conjure up theories
yeah I bet I mean that's come on the
three of them just die yeah one dude
dies and has all [ __ ] on him yeah
cause one of the guys died wanted to
sleep whatever last week or so and I
brought it up and it's like okay but one
person could die randomly but then if
it's three in the middle three all in
similar business yeah that's that's yeah
so no one finds it weird that not one
but three crypto billions died I know it
no we all find it weird yeah we know we
all do nobody's arguing with that
someone must really hate these crypto
Billiards or they screaming out a ton of
money
wow time to sleep
and then over here it gets this deep cut
here this Twitter follower at delete
shitcoin put CI in the Mossad and PDO
Elite are running some kind of sex
trafficking entrapment blackmail ring
out of Puerto Rico and Caribbean islands
they're going to frame oh this is what
homeboy said before he died they're
gonna frame me with a laptop plan by my
ex-girlfriend it was a spy they would
torture me to death and he died this the
guy that died the next day wow
CIA Mossad and pedo Elite are running
some kind of sex trafficking entrapment
blackmail ring out of oh man
now after he died
but three possible futures for me
suicide by say see I brain damage slave
asset worst nightmare of people who
[ __ ] with me up until now I'm sure
these are the only options I think he
might have killed himself that's yeah
like he's a little crazy right send
himself up yeah
yeah it's time
maybe the dog killed off I can't believe
you just said I can't get over that
murderous dog that is exactly what
happened the dog's killing everybody
a Mighty Duck star was a cryptocurrency
billionaire a mighty Dutch child star
which one
uh Brock Pierce I don't know who that is
though
they tried to remake Mighty Ducks
I mean when I say try it was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show
yeah does he look familiar
um uh let's do my detox and see this kid
yeah I can't I don't think he's like a
man Frank who your favorite who's your
favorite actor besides me obviously
picked just one
favorite movie of all time
hey man rocky rocky the first one is
probably the best yeah I will deep
throat you
stupid questions dude that's aggressive
favorite favorite ice cream I'll pull
your hair if you do favorite type of
pizza thank you
thanks for coming in is that it that's
pretty much flight in 10 minutes all
right yeah right you can't be flying out
there for that what are you doing I
can't wait though I I like that guy he's
crazy see how much he eats lift weights
do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] who's this
liver King you gotta fly out there I
wish I said with liver King no no real
quick really what's your stance on
Liberty oh nice I mean dude you know I
mean everybody [ __ ] know look at the
guy right exactly I don't know what you
guys are talking about
see a lot of people would say you know
you and your Heyday like you can't have
a physique that nice and be natural he's
got a nice body a lot of chat right yeah
he's actually never chatter about you
yeah
he just show up yeah
so Franco um any plugs podcasts all that
stuff yeah champion and shrimp yeah
um Champion the [ __ ] yeah come check us
out we're uh
not as good as these guys but we do all
right
you're a hell of a Salesman
Frank Yeager ladies and gentlemen
Frankie we love you as a champ he's
coming in late and doing this dude I
love you brother I appreciate it we're
out